we actually are able to put a value on
that but we as a society do not do not
have a right to put a gauge on beauty
but they do Chaska
I never said that there was anything
wrong with that at the end of the day
I'm just saying that I can't I don't see
it the same way that's why I'm saying
like I feel like like when you say that
it's not that because you actually think
you're perfect it's because it's because
you think like you don't like societies
like beauty standards and it's kind of
like your way of rebellion we think I'm
beautiful but then you are question me
on it and the only way that I can answer
is the way that they can understand
because when I start saying like because
I think I'm beautiful but they're like
why why do you think you're 10 out of
10. what is it that makes you out of 10
out of 10 and it's like